[موسيقى]
قبال
السي قبال
السبال السينا رجال محمد نحنا رجال محمد
ونحنا رجال محمد وحنا رجال محمد
ويا ابو عبيده يا مغوار ويا ابو عبيده يا
مغوار ويا ابو عبيده يا مغوار ويا ابو عبي
يا موار سمعنا صوت العنزان سمعنا صوت
العنزان وسمعنا صوت العنزان سمعنا شو
الا الحدود وافتح لنا ه
حدودك منعود على خس بدنا
نعود اشمع سمع كل
مجاهدات وما بخاف مجاهدات وما بخاف وسيري
سيري يا انا سيري سيري يا حماس وطيري طيري
يا حماس سيري سيري يا حماس وانت المط
واحنا انت المطع واحنا نصار يلا يا شعب
فلسطين يلا يا شعب فلسطين وع الشهاده وع
التحرير عشهد على التحرير و يا حمال
الاربيجي ويا حمال الاربجي يا حمال
الاربيجي يا عمال الاربيجي بكره الناصر رح
يجي بكره الناصر رح يجي تحي ترابك يا
فلسطين تحي ترابك يا فلسطين وفل تحيا
المجاهدين فل تحي المجاهدين ويا مجاهد
الله معاك ويا مجاهد الله معاك ويا مجاهد
الله معاك يا مجاهد الله معاك بيت الاقصى
بيستناك بيت الاقصى بيستناك ويا مجاهد سير
سير يا مجاهد سير سير ويا مجاهد ير كير
ويا مجاهد سير سير واحنا معك على التحرير
واحنا معك على التحرير لا بنسلم ولا رح
نركع لا بنسلم ولا رح نركع لا بنسلم
وسلم y